[inaudible]
it's throwing.
You might be a country that you've only
heard about on the Eurovision song
contest.
If you watch the Eurovision song contest
where the reality is that Estonia is a
pioneer in country in many fields,
some might even call it the Silicon
Valley of Europe.
Companies like skype and transfer wise
were created in Estonia.
This is particularly surprising given
the just 30 years ago,
Estonia was a part of the Soviet Union.
In fact,
the geographically Astonia situation is
far from being ideal there.
Weather is pretty terrible and in the
winter they have as little less three
hours of daylight every day.
They also have an ongoing demographic
crisis that they are really struggling
to solve further,
unlike most countries,
the female population of this stonier is
markedly higher than the male
population.
This means that people find it harder to
find a partner and have children.
This is why every year Estonia maintains
the course of population reduction and
yet despite all of this,
Estonia is the most technologically
advanced nation in all of Europe.
In fact,
it is the only country in Europe where
access to the Internet is recognized in
the constitution,
but what really makes us stoney or get
into our countries all of fame is it's
your residence.
This means that a person,
no matter where they are from can simply
fill out a form and is become a virtual
citizen of Estonia.
But the question you might have in your
mind right now is,
but what does that really mean today?
We are going to explain this to you in
this video,
but first let's have a quick look at the
history of stds.
Yeah.
It's big themes of Vladimir Poutine in
1991 is stonier got its independence
from the Soviet Union.
Yes.
Other countries like Belarus and
Ukraine,
God,
their independence at around the same
time
time,
those countries,
the new political establishment that had
a lot of influence from the old
communist elite Estonia was different.
Their first democratic Prime Minister
Martin Law Form Day cabinets with an
average age of just 30 years old.
These were young people with new ideas.
You had no dance to the old Soviet guard
and this is how it's stonier opens their
markets to the international economy.
They adopted a capitalist system and a
fairly unique political system that
would become well known for its
minimalism.
In fact,
it is this word minimalism that really
describes a stony are better than any
other,
even if their flag as minimalist and is
simply a representation of their
traditional lands.
Even their taxation
is minimalist and they have a flat rate
tax system.
This means that everyone in the country
pays the same percentage of tax,
no matter how much they earn.
In this case in Estonia,
the income tax is just 20% with these
policies,
it's easy to see why your stone,
you're attracted foreign investments,
particularly from the Scandinavian
countries.
Nonetheless,
this was still not enough for them to
grow at the rate they want it at the
beginning of the 1990 is less than a
half of the population had a phone in
their home.
Further.
The infrastructure which was built
during the Soviet era was far for an
acceptable,
as you can imagine,
this is not a great setup for a country
if it isn't looking for economic
development.
Since the country you had no money to
invest in physical roads,
they instead decided to invest in
virtual roads,
be countries,
telecommunications infrastructure,
and just 15 years later it's stonier was
the first country in the world to have
an electronic voting system.
Hold on for just a second because all of
these reforms didn't exactly come for
free.
During these 15 years of forward
progress,
the Russian minority,
which used to rule the country,
became increasingly politically
isolated.
This is why in 2007 the Kremlin under
Vladimir Putin decided,
yeah,
and this is how the first cyber attack
in history,
it was organized and yes,
a cyber attack on a country that relied
heavily on its digital infrastructure
was a big problem.
During the attack,
Estonia lost its administration,
which was so dramatic that even
hospitals were not able to function.
This is why since that day,
Nita has had its cybersecurity
headquarters in Tallinn,
the Estonian capital bars.
This was not the end of Estonia has
problems manage.
She'll crisis.
Two years later,
in 2009 the financial crisis struck
Estonia hot the country.
It was particularly exposed because of
all its foreign investments.
All of a sudden,
the country had no money.
Plus this was the time when they were
supposed to adopt the euro as their
currency.
So even if they wanted to make the
switch to the euro,
they didn't have the funds to make that
happen.
So the government had two options.
They could either cut their spending or
they can raise taxes.
Unlike other countries like Spain,
Estonia took the first option.
In a matter of months,
the government fired over 10,000
workers.
This was about a third of their entire
staff,
politicians and lowered their salary.
Reason froze all state investments,
which included many construction
projects.
All of these carts caused the Estonian
GDP to fall by a 14% in that year to
make a comparison in their worst year
during the financial crisis,
the u s or their GDP fall by 8%
nonetheless,
after going through a terrible 2009
Estonia saw its economy began to improve
almost to me.
Yeah.
Since they didn't raise their taxes and
business policies remained very
flexible.
Many of those who lost their jobs at
decided to start companies.
So now let's have a look at that.
Unemployment shot between 2008 and 2009
is through near went from a 4%
unemployment rate to a 19% unemployment
rate at the time that this was the
highest unemployment rate in all of
Europe,
even higher than Greece and Spain.
However,
the interest,
two years,
they cut this in half and now they have
an admirable 6% unemployment rate and
it's the same goes for their salaries.
Today a person working in Tallinn is
lung thing to be making more money than
most people in southern Europe.
In summary,
Estonia is a model for other countries
to follow and now we're going to have a
look at the key aspects of this country
which did make it quite so sick.
Assassin
ministration it's Tony a pioneer,
the idea of creating a digital id card.
Now many other countries have been
copying this model but it's not
something that has ever been as
successful as it wasn't a stone yet.
The reason that it is so successful in
Estonia is because this ID card is
actually useful.
For instance,
during the elections,
any Estonian citizen can take this med
card,
it cause you any computer and vote
electronically from wherever they are.
There is no need for any sort of
registration.
This is incredibly useful if you are on
holiday during an election or if you are
someone who did something
every,
no yours,
the hassle of voting while abroad having
to go to the embassy and cast a ballot,
it's all a big headache.
Further,
in addition to all of this hassle,
there have been cases where boots from
abroad have simply been lost further.
In Estonia,
you can use this ID card to do any sort
of government business and that includes
paying your taxes and forget about all
of those long forms that are the tax
authorities making.
Yeah,
lounge.
Darn.
Yeah.
You can do everything from your mobile
phone in a matter of minutes.
In fact,
the government has access to the banks
so they can simply find your income.
This happens in every other country
including the u s the only difference is
that in Estonia they think it's stupid
to ask her the same question twice.
So you simply go over your citizen
profile,
confirm that everything's correct and
pay your taxes just like that.
Bye.
Hold on for one minutes because the best
is yet to come.
Imagine that an unscrupulous government
employee you wants to spy on your
personal data.
Well then when that happens you will get
a notification on your government's
profile.
You can even see exactly who that
governments employee is,
who is looking at your data and then if
you want so you can ask them why they
aren't doing it.
This means Estonia in this regard has a
way more transparency than any other
democracy,
but if you still think this is not
enough,
here's the part that really puts Estonia
over the,
yes,
he residency.
We've all heard about these big
companies that place that fiscal
headquarters in places like Panama or
Luxembourg.
However,
this kind of tax structure is almost
impossible for a freelancer or an SME.
I live in Luxembourg and if you want to
start a company in Luxembourg,
you have to go.
You have to start by going to the notary
and to go to the notes or it takes you
three weeks to get an appointment and
then you have to pay a lot of money on.
There's an awful lot of bureaucracy and
everything like that.
Well,
in Estonia they realized that they
needed and you citizens,
as I said,
the country faces a demographic crisis
and well,
welfare,
weather socks.
That is why in 2014 they decided to
offer their cutting edge infrastructure
to the whole world no matter where you
come from and so you might,
no one's out.
Why is this quite so useful?
Of course this is not the same as an
actual citizenship and you can't use the
residency as a passport,
but it is a digital identity issued by a
European governments and this certainly
helps if you want to make international
transactions or open a bank accounts.
In Estonia,
this might be particularly useful if you
are watching this video from places like
the Ukraine or weld Venezuela.
The virtual card also makes it very easy
for you to establish a company in
Estonia and you can do that without
having to move there or do a lot of
complicated.
Wow.
Okay.
Well now I hear you saying is stony is
got to be a fiscal haven,
right?
Well,
actually no,
corporate tax is 20% which is the same
as Finland's for example.
What is thrown at really offers is two
main things,
simplicity and to rule of law.
No,
maybe you think that is too little to
offer,
but the reality is over 10,000 people
have already signed up for this virtual
residency.
One of them is actually the Japanese
Prime Minister Shinzo Abe.
In other words,
it's Stonier has invented a brand's new
concepts.
The concept of liquid citizens.
I know it is all big question for you.
Do you think other countries will follow
the Estonian model?
Do you think there is a time when
everyone were ones who were racist,
stony,
and citizenship?
You can leave your answer in the comment
section below and do not forget that we
put our brand new videos every Monday
and Thursday and you should subscribe to
this channel if you want to get those.
There will be a logo on the screen now
that you can click also a button below
the video and hey,
if you enjoyed this video,
please do give it a thumbs up below.
And as always,
I'll see you next time
I get home this afternoon.
They'll get back to hotel this evening.
I'm going to open a bank account,
stop my company and become an active.
Just,
yeah.